comme chaque week-end cet été nous
poursuivons ce soir notre série de
randonnée sur les sentiers de la région
balade dans la forêt de saint germain
dans les yvelines entre saint germain
les maisons laffitte la nature est aux
portes de la ville caroline douillet
patrick goupillon
en forêt de saint germain on trouve les
signes d'une foi religieuse qui a
traversé les temps une promenade
historique et botanique à deux pas de la
ville
les plus courageux pourront la faire
jusqu'au bout elle dure cinq heures
point de départ sur la grande terrasse
du château de saint germain qui domine
tout paris
les pavés au sous bois ont tout de suite
sur le chêne des anglais
c'est sous cet arbre qu'au xviie se
morfondait un prince anglais exilé il y
demandait pitié à la vierge
et surprise la tradition continue
aujourd'hui il faut marcher encore pour
trouver la croix la plus ancienne de la
forêt lacroix cuisine
elle doit pour cela date de 14 cents
cinquante six années de la
réhabilitation de jeanne d'arc
son ancien compagnon d'armes du noah le
bâtard d'orléans à cette époque
capitaine gouverneur de saint germain
lorée fait ériger pour commémorer
l'événement
le sentier des oratoires réunit en fait
qu'une dizaine de croix de niche poser
dans toute la forêt au cours des siècles
pour vénérer la vierge ou les seins
anne d'autriche mère de louis xiv fit
installer celle ci en l'honneur de
sainte anne cette forêt royale depuis
longtemps ensuite la proximité du
château explique que les événements se
sont produits qu'il y a eu du personnage
important qu'ils ont voulu marquer leur
marque qui lie à une contestable le mans
une une influence religieuse importante
à l'époque et de ce fait classe a s'est
trouvée un peu concentré dans la forêt
l'histoire mais aussi pédagogique près
de maisons laffitte le sentier botanique
fut créée par une institutrice pour
apprendre à reconnaître les diverses
essences d'arbres saules frênes
châtaignier érables observez bien la
forme des feuilles l'aspect du temps
mais c'est parfois beaucoup plus subtil
regardez bien comment différencier un
chêne pédonculé d'un chêne rouvre ça
peut toujours servir
donc ça c'est une cuve de glands de
chênes pédonculés avec un pédoncule très
long il était donc hull c'est le
pédoncule c'est la fête tiges 1 qui
relie le gland à la branche est celui
qui n'a pas de paix dont recul c'est un
chêne rouvre pas de difficulté majeure
sur ce chemin mais attention aux orties
évidemment on entend parfois les avions
ou les trains on appelle ça une forêt
périurbaine
c'est la porte de la nature facile
d'athlé par le rer
mais est ce encore une vraie forêt sans
doute les écosystèmes sont peut-être pas
aussi complexe que dans une forêt
primaire
mais on trouve encore beaucoup de choses
à mon avis intéressante des grands
animaux les chevreuils aussi des petits
animaux et puis beaucoup de plantes
parfois même des plantations
la nature n'est donc pas loin de paris
un premier pas qui vous donnera sans
doute en vue d'en faire d'autres pour
vous enfoncer dans des forêts plus
lointaines